If I wanted to start the perfect
business, these are the things that I
would focus on. So, think of these like
the five advantages [music] that make
any business easier to grow and way more
profitable. And this is what's helped me
build a portfolio of companies that
generated over $250 million in revenue
last year alone.
>> [music]
>> And so, for each one, I'll describe what
it is, I'll give you examples, and I'll
show you industries that excel in them
and industries that suck. There are very
few businesses that have all five, and
even having one of these makes the
business that you have better than
others. And so, just think of this video
as like an S-tier ranking for
opportunity vehicle. So, if you've ever
heard or thought, "Man, like I feel like
I've got a you know, level 10 skill set
and a level two opportunity," then this
video is for you. So, let's get started
with number one. Sticky. It's the most
important thing. If you do not have
what's called revenue retention, you
have nothing. Revenue retention just
means how much revenue from last year
you retain to the next year. That's all
it is. If you don't have that, you will
always be in the sales business. So,
John Paul DeJoria, who started Paul
Mitchell, he started Patron, he says
this quote that I always remember. He
says, "You want to be in the resale
business, not in the sales business."
And so, there's two types of retention
that people discuss. One is logo
retention, which is if you had 100
customers in January, how many do you
have now? And then, the second is the
revenue retention piece, which is if you
made $100 from those customers in
aggregate in January, how much do you
make from that same cohort or group of
customers today? And so, logo retention,
just to be clear, you almost never have
100% logo retention. Like, you can't get
more than 100%. You only have a certain
amount of customers, and it only decays
over time. And so, some reasons for that
is that there's something called
structural churn. So, someone moves
away, they die, they're, you know, their
business dies, there's a, you know, they
fire the employee if you do a payroll
thing who used the subscription or the
service. And this is called involuntary
churn. It's because it's just structural
to how businesses operate, right? On the
other hand, there's something called
voluntary churn. And this is the one you
really want to avoid. That's when people
leave because they just think you suck,
right? And so, those are kind of like
from a logo retention perspective, how
many of the number of people are still
here? The revenue retention side, you
absolutely can have over 100% net
revenue retention. And so, that means
that even if you lose some of those
customers, the ones who stay increase
how much they spend enough to make up
for the ones you lost. And so, the
easiest way to do this is have a clear
way for cheaper customers to spend more
with you. And if you're a service, keep
doing the thing they need you to do,
which part of it is making sure that
that person that you sell actually needs
it in the first place. And this is why
qualifying customers is so important.
But, for example, if I have a $9 month
membership and a $99 month membership,
like School, if someone comes in at $9
and then goes up to 99, then I get an
11x in terms of value from that
customer. And so, even if 20% of
customers leave from the nine, if I get
even 10% of customers to take an 11x, I
have more than 100% revenue retention,
and that means that when a customer
enters the business, that means that the
business will continue to grow whether
we do nothing at all over time. And that
becomes a very valuable company. Now,
let me give you some interesting data on
School that manages hundreds of
thousands of memberships that you can
use for any recurring business. Number
one is that the first amount of churn
that's the greatest is month one. So, if
you ever have to focus, focus first on
your first 30 days.
It across all categories it was over 20%
plus churn in that first month, all
right? The next big kind of like
drop-off point in churn is about 10%,
and that happens at about month three.
The third and kind of final spot where
you have a big drop in in churn is month
six. And so, the big takeaway here is do
whatever you can to get people to month
six. So, in your mind you might be like,
"How am I going to keep them forever?"
It's like you really just got to get
people to that sixth month, which really
means make sure the first 30 days are
awesome, and then have a clearer way to
get them past that third month, and then
you basically
walk your way to month six, and at that
point churn drops to almost 2% a month.
And that's across all categories. All
right, so this is just structural to how
people consume and value memberships or
recurring subscriptions of any kind. And
so, please take this as like this is
where I'm going to focus all of my
attention to get people that 2% churn,
which means we just got to get them to
month six.
So, let me give you examples of
businesses that are not sticky. So,
education on its own is not a sticky
thing. That's why you graduate when you
go to school. Like, you're not going to
go and retake the same math class over
and over again. Um roofing, car sales,
these are businesses that do not have a
lot of stickiness to them. They're
one-time shots, right? On the other
hand, a good example of sticky
businesses is term life insurance. You
sign up for life insurance and you
pretty much just pay until you die,
right? Uh alarm systems, like you don't
really think, "Oh, I'm going to shop my
alarm system." You have it, as long as
it works, you're good to go. Internet,
phone providers, banking. Um
and to use that kind of education, a
different version of that for like
school, for example, is if you have
something that's based on community, and
something that's based on consumables,
meaning people consume it month over
month over month, then it means that
they're going to want to pay month over
month over month. And so, if I could
only have one thing for of these five,
it would be this, right? And so, think
about it like this. Let's imagine
company A and company B. So, company one
sells 100 customers year one, and then
loses 100 customers year one. Year two,
uh they sell 200 customers cuz they get
better at marketing and sales, and then
they lose 200 customers. And then year
three, they sell 300 new customers, and
then they lose 300 new customers, all
right? Now, company B, same time period,
sells 100 customers, and then loses
zero. Year two, they sell 100 customers
again. They don't scale their sales and
marketing at all. But now they have the
original 100, so now they have 200
active customers, which means they
actually have the same revenue. Year
three, they sell another 100 customers,
they still have the first two, and they
have 300 customers in total, meaning
both of these businesses in each of
these years is doing the same revenue.
Of these, which would you pick? Company
A or company B? Obviously company B. And
so, I'll give you two reasons. One
that's uh personal and one that's math.
On a personal level, the idea that you
could just have no new customers at any
given point, and then every year after
that you still have your 300 customers
who pay you over and over and over
again, that helps you sleep at night
great. Now, from a math perspective,
getting 300 new customers in a year is
very expensive. So, look at how many
total customers this business needed to
acquire over that period of time. So,
they had to acquire twice as many
customers as company B. All that
additional cost is taken out of the
profit of the business. But, on top of
that, getting 600 customers versus 300,
and especially 300 one year versus 100,
the cost of getting that additional
customer is not going to be just 1x
more. Often times it's two or three
times more. So, it's really almost like
getting 900 customers from a cost
perspective compared to that 300 that
you had to get and spread it over three
years. The cash flow of the business,
the profitability of the business will
be significantly higher, and as an
owner, way more fun to own. And this is
just like me talking to my younger self,
building a business that does this
takes time. But, what it unlocks is
compounding. And so, the reason that you
don't usually want to do this B thing is
because you're excited to jump from
thing to thing, because your current
thing still feels month to month. Once
you see compounding unlock and you see
revenue lock in, you really never
consider other vehicles because you can
literally just excel sheet out your
wealth knowing exactly how big you're
going to be in the future because you
know the customers you have today are
going to be there tomorrow. Real quick,
I'm going to show you the exact 10-stage
roadmap from zero to 100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish.
I've now done multiple times, and so I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages as head count
increases that you need to get through.
And I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products, uh service businesses, brick
and mortar, all of this, and it works.
And it's my gift to you, it's absolutely
free. And so, the link's in the
description, but you just go
acquisition.com/roadmap.
Just enter your info and it'll spit it
right back to you all free. Now, the
second thing that I see is like a a big
advantage, you really never consider
other vehicles because you can literally
just excel sheet out your wealth knowing
exactly how big you're going to be in
the future because you know the
customers you have today are going to be
there tomorrow. Now, the second thing
that I see is like a a big advantage is
expensive. So, what does that mean? In a
perfect world, you'd want something that
costs a penny that you could sell for a
buck, right? High gross margins means
that you can pay people better, your
cash conversion cycle is typically
faster, you can reinvest that cash in
more growth, and this typically has
higher EBITDA margins. So, if you have
high gross margin, you'll typically have
higher net margins. And so, for example,
if I had a hundred million dollar
business with 10% margins versus a 20
million dollar business with 50%
margins, you'd make the same money at
the end. Now, you get five times the
incremental EBITDA per dollar made, and
that's certainly nice. It's less work
for more money. Now, this was the topic
of my money models book that I spent a
lot of time on, and the goal was to see
how you can combine things to speed up
the money cycle and increase gross
margins and cash flow in the business.
So, let me give you some examples of
businesses that have low gross margins.
So, grocery stores, right? They're
notoriously gross small gross margins.
Farming, restaurants, and you'll notice
that all these are kind of grouped
around one thing is because food is one
of the most elastic products, so take
note to that. But fundamentally, it's
really like things that are commodities,
which is why the first chapter that I
have in the Offers book is how to
decommoditize yourself so that you can
increase your gross margins, so you can
ultimately get the cash you need to
grow. Now, on the flip side, examples of
good businesses that have great gross
margins, media. I mean, think about it.
A podcast read that you do when you've
got a thousand people listening or a
million people listening takes the same
effort, and all of the extra that you
can charge is just profit, right? Uh
information, that's one. Education
itself, um community access, these are
things that have high gross margins.
Data, software, pharmaceuticals, right?
It costs them a penny to make a pill and
they sell it for a buck. Um lotions and
potions, it doesn't cost a lot to
create, you know, a supplement, you can
sell it for a lot. All of these things
are businesses that have high gross
margins. Now, quick disclaimer, many of
you wonder what you should pick or
whether you're in the right boat. And as
a reminder, this doesn't mean you watch
this video and then like jump ship in
your business.
Um but you should at least see the
levers that you have available to you to
improve the the value of the business
you have right now. And to be clear, all
of these are continuums, not binaries.
It's not is it sticky or not sticky,
it's how sticky is it. It's not like,
oh, this has, you know, zero gross
margins or 100% gross margins, it's how
how big is the gross margin? And all the
way down. So that brings me to the third
one, which is expansion. I want
something that is growing, right? That's
the best It's the easiest way to grow is
to go into something that's already
growing, so if you just do a normal
amount, you still grow by default. And
so, I'm thinking about this more as an
industry growing rather than the
business itself growing. The business
growth would often come down to
marketing and distribution, and I can do
that, so that's not something that I
care as much about. This is a skill
advantage to us as entrepreneurs picking
the right markets, because once you know
how to generate demand, then you don't
need to always have a tailwind behind
you, you just need to not be in a a
headwind, fundamentally, right? Make
sure you're just not fighting an uphill
battle. I speak about this in the Offers
book. And the main reason is this, even
if you know how to market and sell,
going into or staying in a space that's
shrinking is an uphill battle. And this
is why I use the example of newspapers.
Most people are like, I don't really
read the newspaper, it every single year
goes down. If you're like, hey, I want
to get into formal education, probably
not the time to do it because it's going
it's shrinking by 6% a year. All right?
Uh tobacco, shrinking. Alcohol,
shrinking, right? Retail, like brick and
mortar where you're selling stuff, not
to say you can't make money in it, it's
just harder, right? Uh administrative
roles, clerical, data entry, these are
things that normal in how the world
works. Now, the flip side is, what are
examples of industries that are growing?
Energy, going through the roof. AI,
through the roof. Healthcare,
through the roof. Cybersecurity, through
the roof. E-commerce, through the roof.
Alternative education, through the roof.
And this is what fundamentally the bet
that I made on school was about. The
CAGR, so compound annual growth rate for
alternative education is over 20%
annually, right? People are tired of of
traditional education, and this is why
platforms like YouTube are proliferating
like crazy. People want to learn
specific niche skills that are useful to
them. Which brings me to, drumroll,
please, number four big advantage that
you want to have, air. You want
something that has operational scale or
low operational complexity and low
capex. So, let me define each of those.
So, low operational complexity means the
number of variables that you need to
actively manage to expand production.
So, if I make a podcast, like I said
earlier, and then I sell an ad read
inside of that podcast, someone gives me
money, I read it, and then I hit post.
That's pretty much it. There's nothing
else. And that scales all the way up,
right? And so, that's low operational
complexity. Now, if I manage a hundred
restaurants of a chain, I have thousands
of employees, I have suppliers, I have
inventory that goes bad, I have
build-outs, I have leases, I have
parking, I have permitting, and there
are many more pieces that I need to
actively manage in order to expand
production even a small incremental
unit. The other side is capex, which is
just a fancy way of saying capital
expenditure, meaning how much money you
got to spend to get the business to keep
growing. Now, there's a little asterisk
on this cuz I'm going to explain why it
can be a good thing um when I bring up
my very last point. So, wait and and pay
attention to the end because it's going
to be very important for number five.
Now, the reason that this is valuable as
a founder is you typically would need
less capital, which means you can dilute
less for your ownership, for equity, uh
for cash to continue expanding. Which
means you can expand faster without
needing money from the outside. So,
Warren Buffett talks about this because
he wants businesses that generate lots
of cash, not ones that generate it and
then have to consistently reinvest that
cash in order to maintain
competitiveness in the business. And so,
this is the important caveat. If you
raise capital to grow faster, you could
have all the correct economics, you just
want to grow faster. That is a strategy,
it's an advanced one, um but if you're
trying to capture market share and
capturing market share has actual
advantages beyond the economics of
scale, like we'll make it up in volume,
it's rarely true, but if it actually is
true, then there is reason to go get
market share, actually have some sort of
network effect.
That makes sense. In my experience, it's
very rare, right? School is a great
example of actually it doing it right.
Additional users to school do not cost
very much. But getting everyone on
school is worth doing because there are
strong network effects. And so it's
worth us putting more cash in now rather
than taking distributions. Said
differently, taking that cash and
putting it into the business yields
tremendous ROIC, which means return on
invested capital. And if you have great
ROIC, then you become a magnet for
money. So this is just a little pro tip.
You should never have any difficulty
raising money if you are in a business
that's like that because if you do, it
means that you need to make the deal
better. Let's say you have a restaurant
chain and you want to grow it. And I to
be fair, I think it's a very tough thing
to do. But if you wanted to grow it and
if you're like, man, I can't get people
to, you know, invest in my franchise or
want to buy franchise locations, like
how do I have a better, you know,
marketing strategy? For sure, there's
things you could do to market and sell
better. But if you come to somebody and
say, "Hey, you know, it costs 100 grand
to open my thing, it'll take 3 years in
order for you to get your money back."
That's kind of like a mediocre-ish
offer. If you say it's going to cost 100
grand to do my thing and then you're
going to make $300,000 back on average
in the first year, that's going to be a
significantly more enticing offer. And
so for most people who want to use
outside capital in order to scale, the
reason they can't raise it is not
because they don't lack some big skills,
because the core economics of the thing
they're trying to scale just aren't that
good. And so the fifth and final is
unique. So you want a competitive moat,
something that no one else can build.
Now part of what can raise the bar and
create a larger moat is the number of
people who can afford to enter the
market. So if you have a market that has
virtually no barriers to entry, you'll
have a lot of competition. And this can
be a huge driving factor. So for
example, social media marketing
agencies, the bar is virtually nothing.
It can be sticky, it can be high gross
margin,
it is kind of an expanding thing, people
always want more customers. It can be
air from a capex perspective, but from
an operational drag perspective, it's
not as good. Now, with AI, it can
actually become really interesting. But,
the main issue is so many people can do
it, and that's what makes it so
competitive, and that's ultimately what
drives down the price cuz it's very
difficult to differentiate. Now, let me
explain what I was saying earlier about
capex as a way to have a moat. So, if
you are competing against every human
being who has hands to dig holes, if you
buy a shovel, you'll be significantly
better than people who don't have a
shovel, and that'll cost you a little
bit of money. That'll make you more
efficient. And so, in a way, you can
actually use capital that you do to
invest up front into building things
that make it less competitive for you
and more competitive for other people to
try and enter your marketplace. This is
why like building a power plant is
probably very profitable. It also costs
a lot of money, right? [laughter] And
so, um these are things that you can do
to any business. If you find can have a
return on invested capital for things
like technology, for things like
equipment, um those become moats that
make it more difficult for other people
to enter, which means that you'll have
more pricing power. And so, once you
start to see some success, I like
getting into businesses that cost some
capital to expand because it just means
that I have fewer people that I have to
compete with. Now, up to this point,
I've only talked about capital as a kind
of moat. Now, to be clear, it's not
indefensible, but it's better than
nothing. But, the best kind of moats are
the things that you know how to do, but
no one else can do. So, for example,
Nvidia chips. This is something that
costs a ton of money and has incredibly
specialized skills. So, as a result,
they're one of the seven most valuable
companies in the world, right? Pretty
wild. Uh nuclear energy costs a lot of
money and is something that's super
proprietary, not a lot of people know
how to do. If you didn't have the
capital, then it would be recipes,
processes, patents. These are trade
secrets, your special sauce. And just as
a side note, you're like, "Well, what
differentiates, uh you know, like a
trade secret from a patent?" Well,
patent just requires three things. It's
got to be new, it's got to be
non-obvious, and it's got to be useful.
Those are from the patent office. All
right, so if you're thinking about,
"What are the things in my business that
are brand new that I only do, that are
not obvious, and that are useful. Those
things are patentable, right? Kind of
cool. Now, you have to defend patents,
which is a whole another story, but
that's a way of creating a moat. Now,
one of my favorite ways of creating a
moat is creating a brand. You can make
anything that's a commodity unique by
adding a brand to it. So, for example,
Revlon is kind of like a mass-market
brand for beauty stuff. You can get it
at CVS, whatever. And you might think,
"Oh, that's a that's a cheap brand."
Now, the point though is that even if
Revlon is cheap, it's still a little bit
more expensive than white-label generic.
So, CVS might have some CVS brand
makeup, right? Revlon's going to be a
little bit more expensive than that.
But, they literally will come off the
exact same manufacturing belt, and
they'll stamp on Revlon, and they'll
stamp on CVS, and they'll ship them
there. And that premium converts a
higher percentage of people at a higher
price, and increases the stickiness. And
so, a brand is one of my favorite ways
of taking something that's otherwise a
very normal service, and making a moat,
or making something unique about it. So,
let me give you a different example that
that manages some of these, all right?
So, Coke requires capital to enter new
markets, but it gets great returns on
capital, so people are happy to provide
it, or it can provide capital to itself,
and get returns on its own capital. And
it has patents for the flavor of Coke,
and the brand itself. And so, these are
things And if we're looking at this,
right? When people start drinking Coke,
they usually keep drinking it for a long
time. It costs a few pennies to make a
can of Coke in terms of the liquid
inside of it, but they can sell for a
lot more than that. Now, is it expanding
as a marketplace? I think Coke's pretty
global, and I guess the only expansion
is just more human drinking stuff. So, I
guess there's probably right now still
some expansion that's happening. From an
operational scale perspective, this is
one where it's a little harder. Now, is
it easier than scaling an accounting
firm globally? Absolutely. Is it harder
than scaling software globally? Yes. And
so, it's kind of like in the middle on
this one. And then, unique, what it does
to create that uniqueness so so Shasta
Cola doesn't take over the market,
right? Is that it has the brand, and it
has its recipe. And so, those are the
ways that it creates something that is
harder to usurp, which is why Warren
Buffett's been a long-time investor in
the business, and it just continues to
grow and print money. And so that's what
you want. Now you're not going to have
something that has all of these. It's
very very hard to do that. There are
trade-offs, but the perfect business
would include many or all of these. And
if your business includes none, that's
okay, work at retention first, and then
backfill the rest. But if you're in an
industry that has no retention, then
switching to one that does, if you're
early in your career, may not be the
dumbest decision. And so if I were
starting it all over again, this is what
I would look for in a business that I'd
want to start, ideally something that
people keep buying, something that is
expensive relative to what it cost me.
It's in a market that's not going down
at the very least, there's less
operational complexity in order to
scale, and it's unique to me, or at
least I know a way to make it unique to
my customer. Real quick, I'm going to
show you the exact 10-stage road map
from zero to 100 million plus that less
than 1% of companies finish. I've now
done multiple times, and so I can say
with a lot of confidence that these are
the stages, as head count increases,
that you need to get through, and I
broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products,
service businesses, brick and mortar,
all of this, and it works. And it's my
gift to you, it's absolutely free, and
so the link's in the description, but
you just go acquisition.com/roadmap,
just enter your info, and it'll spit it
right back to you, all free.